i want to segue into the story we have
this is from fox news john oliver you
know him you love him says effing let
police officers who resist vaccine
mandates quit oliver argued resistance
to vaccine mandate sums up the core
issue with american police i'm sure it
does but uh we're we're segwaying
segwaying from the story that ultimately
i think you know what we were talking
about kyle written house riots were
talking about how the police were
standing down in the in the george floyd
riots i shouldn't say cut red house
rights the george floyd riots in which
that was the jacob blake riots sorry
yeah there's so many i get confused
sometimes um and we will soon have the
cop right house riots because it's trial
soon but the ultimate result i think is
gonna be cops quitting and so we have
this story which is really interesting
because police are quitting a bunch of
cops i think nypd is suing over the
vaccine mandate is that that's great
chicago they're they're instructing the
officers to defy the mandate in
baltimore they're doing the same thing
the end result i think is going to be
cops quitting and here's the funny thing
we've we've long been saying now like
long as in the past couple of weeks the
left should be cheering for this they
wanted to defund the police abolish the
police they should be happy right turns
out they are fox news reports
last week tonight host john oliver took
aim at police officers who have yet to
get the vaccine
encouraging an effing quit quote the
police are supposed to be keeping the
public safe that is the point of their
jobs yet some don't seem to give much of
an ish about that
the liberal host single liberal host
singled out chicago and new york police
departments is fall uh falling under
that category
cbd officers he noted resisted uploading
their vaccination statuses to a portal
over 20 officers are on no pay status
for refusing to comply he also shared a
video of a pair of nypd officers who
were seen removing a commuter from the
subway while they themselves were
unmasked that video was actually kind of
funny you see it a guy in a mask yells
at the cops to put a mask on so they
kick him out of the subway that's crazy
now
i think they are going to be happy i
think the left is effectively getting
their abolish the police through this
or defund them at the very least well
abolish the police was never really
about abolishing the police it was about
a loyalty test it's making sure that the
police that are going to enforce their
edicts and their decrees are going to
stay there and the people who are going
to question it are of course going to be
kicked out and to me john oliver just
kind of confirmed how much of a loyalty
test these vax mandates are because a
lot of the people who are compliant a
lot of the people who are saying yes
i'll just do whatever you tell me are
the people who have taken the vax some
of the people who can't take the vax or
don't want to take the facts or more
people who are not in line with the
state who question the state who still
are waiting for a lot of the data to
come in are people who are usually
skeptical of centralized authorities so
this to me is going to shift things in a
major dramatic way as of course there's
estimates that major cities could lose
one-third of their police forces because
of these mandates now when you have such
a huge loss with crime already going up
dramatically in cities this is a recipe
for a disaster and to me
only propagates a situation where of
course you're going to have politically
divided people more and more in certain
areas that may or may not go against
each other but we also have the news
that in florida the governor there ron
desantis is offering police officers
five thousand dollars in a signing bonus
if they refuse to take the vaccine and
relocate to florida and decide to give
these police officers there indiana as
well five thousand dollars
i don't know the number but there's uh
there's a push there's an indiana police
department that said that they're going
to welcome all the chicago police
officers uh whichever police officers do
not want to take the vaccine
there's also a chicago police union
president that has been uh censored he
can't speak about the vaccine and what's
going on right now uh but before he was
censored by a court he was making some
pretty good points about how a lot of
these policies are discriminatory how a
lot of his officers can't take the
vaccine don't want to take the vaccine
have natural hurt immunity he was making
some really good legitimate arguments
but this is a major issue and this
mandate really will be the true loyalty
test that will separate this nation into
very very far away political spectrums
that hopefully are able to stay together
away from each other peacefully there's
a lot of resources
there's a lot of reasons why i thought
we should get away from the city we're
originally in the philadelphia area on
the jersey side
and we wanted to we almost bought a
building out there but sale kind of fell
through and it was just you know cove it
hit and then i thought you know what we
need space we need space we need to
cheat we need cheap space and we should
be in new jersey for a variety of
reasons one of those was that
as much as the cops we had were actually
really good we had we had a small
department with a handful of guys who
were they were quick they were they were
good people i talked to them you know i
would go into the
the the police station and talk to them
and they were great
moderate individuals not crazy trumpers
but certainly not authoritarian
and i just kind of thought
as things get crazy and they issued
these lockdown orders
and just north of where we lived was the
atlas gym where the cops actually came
and arrested arrested a guy i guess ian
smith right ian smith yeah he's the guy
who runs the gym and the initial the
first cops who came came there were like
we're not going to enforce this have a
nice day so they pulled cops from out of
town and i was like if they can do that
staying in this place is a really really
bad idea because the cops aren't going
to protect you they're going to oppress
you they're going to tell you that by
decree you can't leave your home you
can't go to the store you can't do these
things but they're not going to be there
when you need them
and so i thought you know what i would
rather be somewhere with no cops
so where we are right now
if you call the cops they might be here
in i don't know half an hour
longer
and where i live
good luck
it's a mountain
and so like my actual house and as much
as there's still risks there because
then everything's on you one thing i
noticed is that a lot of people have
said
people are actually reluctant to go up
into a mountain full of right-wing nut
jobs and commit crimes because everyone
there is armed to the teeth not that
anybody actually ever shoots anybody
they don't
but
people knowing that cops aren't going to
come
they don't climb a mountain and then try
to rob mountain full in the cities
people got a lot of guns in the cities
too though
yeah but not not usually the criminal
republicans but look look look in new
jersey where i was told explicitly by
the police by multiple departments that
if someone breaks into my house with a
gun and fires at me i have an obligation
to flee my own home
i'm like yeah yep we had someone try to
break in and i'm like what do i do the
one cop goes i'd answer the door the
shotgun and so i looked it up and i
talked to him like oh but if you use it
you'll go to prison
what they said was
it's a semi-castle doctrine state what
that means is you have an affirmative
defense to shoot someone who enters your
home but you will be arrested and
charged first then after you spend a
night in jail and try and get bailed out
bailed out which you might not you can
tell the judge why you were justified
and shooting the man who was trying to
kill you your friends and your family
and so i'm like
i'm gonna have to argue in court that i
don't want to jump from the the we we
didn't have a back door the first floor
went over a balcony because it was on a
hill and i'm like so i got to jump off a
20 store you know for 20 feet up slide
down a pull a beam on my deck
or defend myself with the f i'm getting
out of this state this is insane west
virginia doesn't have those problems my
friend look so you know and
that's good west virginia i wish there
was a lot of problems but does not have
a crime right it has a drug problem it's
a drug problem that's a remarkable it's
a big pharma it's not a drug problem
it's a big pharma problem that's made it
a drug it's a drug problem huh it's a
drug problem yeah it's a drug problem
that was exacerbated by the big pharma
ah now yes i agree
we could do we talked about this
we could debate this later
after show but we could agree to
disagree
um uh
western doesn't but look most most crime
in america not all most primary
increasingly most americans concentrate
in cities hey that's because eighty
percent of people live in metropolitan
areas um so yeah you know you don't get
a lot of crime in rural west virginia
because nobody lives in a royal west
virginia nobody's come out and try to
shoot you um but you know
i think i think we have situated a
conversation in terms of like uh um we
saw the largest single year
percentage-wise in absolute terms
increase in homicide on record last year
uh average results rose 11
uh grand theft auto rose 11
nationwide it was much worse in
individual cities there are cities in
america baltimore chicago where the
homicide rate uh a particular homicide
rate for young black men exceeds a
hundred per hundred thousand that's
the nationwide figure is like six
um that's enormously high rate so that's
crime crime is a real and increasing
problem in the united states uh by
comparison to the rest of the world
crime is an intolerable problem in the
united states twenty thousand fifty
twenty thousand people die a year of
homicide uh compare that rate to any
other developed nation it's
inconceivable that's thing one thing two
is the cultural problem well we have a
whole host of problems but but from you
know the root causes don't matter what
matters is what solves the problem the
answer is we got a lot of really high
quality evidence that police are an
effective tool for reducing crime that
if you put cops in area crime declines
in that area that if you increase police
forces crime goes down we're not talking
about just uh just like minor crimes
talking about homicide but let's think
about those budgets for for a second i
mean
i i've been to some countries where they
have
very they they
they don't have armed cops you know like
south america has the garda they got a
lot of crime for sure in a lot of areas
but
you know what maybe it's
you look at scandinavia and they're
they're an example of how countries are
just very different the left likes to
use them as an example of how proper
placement can be done but then you're
like but they're small and they're
different in the united states we do
have a lot of cops we do have massive
policies we actually we actually so
first of all we don't have mass
blueprint we spend about three percent
of all dollars go to cost there's a
hundred of excuse me of all of all
government spending across local state
and federal it's like what's what's a
comparable country with uh but so so so
the second point is we also spend a huge
amount of money on cos the second point
is like in turn compared to oecd
countries costs per capita we're like in
the middle like we don't actually we've
way more prisoners
per capita our our prison capacity is
enormous uh our cops are like
middling um we absolutely there's
there's uh there's high quality
estimates there's going to be aaron
chalfen at um
uh penn and another fellow whose name is
escaping me who do estimates of the
returns to policing and their argument
is that american cities are
systematically under policed uh for the
simple reason that like the amount of
money that we spend versus the
automotive we could save uh in real
value if fewer people murdered if there
were fewer crimes or fewer thefts if
they're fewer assaults uh
the the benefit the benefits that we
leave on the table dramatically outweigh
the amount of money we're spending now
well there's also another aspect to
entertain here and that's a lot of the
blue flu going around a lot of police
officers refusing to do their job
there's also the fact that the nypd has
you know almost the same amount of of
members as many militaries around the
world almost comparable to
some of the top militaries out there
they have a whole nypd intelligence unit
that literally has spies all over the
world i i would say that you know them
spending five billion dollars is a lot
of money for policing that many times
they decide not to do and participate or
even enforce the the the nypd okay a
militaries and police forces are apples
to oranges the number of things police
forces have to do much larger than the
set of things police forces have to do b
the new york city is a dramatic success
story in terms of public safety if you
look at violent crimes decline since the
1990s uh it's fallen dramatically across
the united states across major cities uh
homicide uh crimes of violence etc
the decrease in new york city is 50
percent larger than other cities um
frank zimmer's our criminologist at uc
berkeley looks at all the relevant
factors that his book on this called uh
the city that became safe and his
argument is that the rude explanation is
basically like there was a transition to
more policing and more and better
policing in new york city in the 90s
like the nypd there are certainly uh it
is an enormous department they spend a
lot of time and a lot of money on a lot
of different things um but it's hard to
argue with the results in terms of crime
reduction new york city in homicide
returns for example looks so much better
than comparable cities in the united
states it's insane how do you compare
what happened within the last few months
and last year when when crime and
violence has gone up so dramatically but
but how do you explain it i mean that's
yes
i'm just asking you legitimately not
trying to contradict you know sure i
mean so so
the last year's trends are i think
alarming and it's unclear and there's a
live debate about what caused the
increase um this is is is it covert and
these are lockdowns i think that there's
some argument there but i find it
ultimately uncompelling for reasons i
can enumerate you know i do think
ultimately if you look at the timing of
when the increases happen if you look at
where they happen uh it comes down to a
concern this goes back to the
conversation a concerted national effort
uh to delegitimize policing to
delegitimize the police like if if you
agree with the claim that cops reduce
crime uh that cop presence reduces crime
and then you start punishing costs for
showing up you start saying it's not
cool to be a cop it's we we hate the
cops we want to defund the police cops
are racist pigs who want to murder us uh
you're going to lose policing capacity
when you lose policing capacity crime is
going to go up and that's what we saw
happen dramatically last year i'm not
sure that explains
let me let me just i think there's so
many variables that we could add on to
this but
there was also mass decarceration we are
by best estimates at like a tenth of the
jail population that we were in march in
february of 2020 um and that's going to
have an impact at the margins um but
like
i i i did some data analysis today i
looked at 9-1-1 calls in seattle because
there's a there's a paper arguing
looking at 9-1-1 calls as evidence that
uh cops lost legitimacy after george
flayed's death and then when calls went
down
and one of the arguments that i make in
response to this paper is
uh data that looks at calls for service
by cops usually looks at both calls by
civilians like you pick up the phone and
call 9-1-1 you're like hey
uh there's a crime but also calls by
cops to uh
uh to the the center that manages
dispatch um
it's hard to disaggregate this data the
people writing these people didn't
disagree with this day that assumed was
all civilians if you look in seattle
which is where you're able to get really
good numbers you look at calls from cops
and you get calls from civilians after
the week after george floyd's death
calls from civilians are flat they
remain the same calls them cops
collapsed 80 70
and have persisted consistently that's a
measure of police activity police
pro-activity uh you can look at
employment in big cities you can look at
the nypd you can look at minneapolis pd
collapsed you can look at stops and
arrests collapsed um by a across metrics
in large not across the country but in
large cities there's good reason to
believe that uh cops cops are doing less
and less practice and you can argue that
that's bad i think it's not great i
would prefer that cops like selflessly
kept going out and doing their jobs no
matter the incentives but you should
also be willing to say like actually the
incentives are pretty bad right now
to actually be a cop and do the cops
work yeah and some elements i definitely
agree with you and i think you did bring
up some important points thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time